bonjour j'espère que vous avez passé une
bonne année 2020 autant que possible
cette année c'est un petit peu plus dire
à dire ce genre de choses mais comme
tous les ans depuis trois ans on va
faire un petit récapitulatif des films
sortis en 2020 que j'ai vu et que j'ai
apprécié évidemment il y en a beaucoup
moins que d'habitude là cette année j'ai
vu 35 films 37 37 films sortis en 2020
et encore pas tous au cinéma
mais voilà on va y aller quand même j'ai
réussi à trouver quelques films que j'ai
apprécié et je vais vous les partager
dès maintenant le premier film dont j'ai
envie de vous parler et les filles du
docteur march little women en vo de
greta gaming on retrouve au casting
search romane florence puech timothée
xala mais emma watson laura dern louis
garrel bref des gens plutôt qualitatif
donc ce film est un nouvelle version des
quatre filles du docteur march qui est
une histoire assez connu que je n'ai pas
lu tu commences à l'avenir un peu mais
j'ai remarqué que ça va passer pour
enfants mais le film quant à lui est
traitée manière beaucoup plus adulte
donc en gros ça raconte l'histoire de
quatre soeurs à plusieurs époques de
leur vie en partie durant la guerre de
sécession ou leur père est absent mais
aussi ensuite donc le film est
entrecoupé d'allers et retours la partie
durant la guerre de sécession où on peut
tout en souffrance mais elles font tout
ensemble
c'est un peu leur enfant ce convoi et la
partie plus tard elle se retrouve tout
un peu séparés qui s'est mariée mais qui
a des problèmes d'argent l'autre qui
essayent de s'en sortir par elle-même et
d'écrire mais c'est compliqué et j'ai
trouvé ça très bien traités le rapport à
la famille les tensions entre les
personnages étaient très bien fait et
les actrices sont magnifiques et joue
super bien
des costumes
les décors étaient plutôt bien aussi
donc voilà pourquoi j'ai apprécié ce
film pour son ambiance j'aime aussi des
films d'époque et les films qui se passe
ce neuvième siècle parle beaucoup aussi
même si le moyen-âge reste dans mon
coeur et du coup pour toutes ces raisons
j'ai beaucoup aimé cette nouvelle
version j'ai pas vu d'autres versions
parce que je suis avec plusieurs
adaptations cinématographiques de ce
livre c'est la seule que j'ai vu et je
l' ai beaucoup aimé le deuxième film
dont nous allons parler je l' ai vu en
tout début d'année 2020 il s'appelle la
vie invisible de redditch egos mahault
où je parle très mal portugais avidan d
hiver théorie dit cheikh osman en vo
réalisé par karim noz avec carole duarte
dans le rôle principal
comme vous l'aurez deviné ce marché du
brésilien qui se passe à rio dans les
années 50
et il raconte le destin de deux heures
encore une histoire de seurre un peu
moins sympathique cette fois en gros ce
sont deux soeurs qui se retrouvent
séparées l'une d'elles rêve de devenir
pianiste l'autre rêve d'aventuré d'amour
et donc cette deuxième soeur s'enfuit un
jour avec un marin vers l'europe tandis
que l'autre est obligé de se marier
parce que c'est comme ça pour une fille
dans les années 50 on la marie avec un
gain qui n'a pas forcément choisi et
donc chacune voit ses rêves plutôt brisé
celle qui rêvait de devenir pianiste et
ben si une femme mariée maintenant donc
elle a d'autres choses à faire quoi et
celles qui rêvaient d'amour et d'eau
fraîche et ben se retrouvent abandonnés
délaissés et le truc c'est que ses
soeurs pourrait se retrouver à tout
moment mais à cause d'un secret ne se
retrouve pas en tout cas je vais pas
vous spoiler tout le film quoi mais le
film dure de nombreuses années et elle
passe des années sans réussir à se
retrouver à
il rejoint qu'une de leur côté et au
final pas si éloignées l'une de l'autre
mais justes elles le savent pas et
c'était une très belle histoire
encore une fois avec de très beaux
décors et très bien joué ça c'est
quelque chose qui va revenir souvent de
façon une très belle retranscription des
années 50 et 60 à rio j'ai trouvé au
niveau de l'ambiance même du grain delà
de l'image et c'était un film assez long
mais au final où je pas je pas du tout
vu le temps passer donc je le recommande
beaucoup je ne sais pas il doit être un
peu moins facile à trouver peut-être que
les blockbusters dont je vais parler ils
partent en blockbusters mais les films
un peu plus diffuser quoi mais si vous
avez l'occasion de le voir regarder le
c'était vraiment très bon pied troisième
film
voilà un peu plus diffusés pour le coup
scandale ou bank shell en vo de jay rock
rock avec charlize theron nicole kidman
et margot robbie trois actrices plutôt
pas mal
donc ce film raconte l'histoire de
rockers reds qui est le créateur de
foxnews fondateur de la chaîne fox news
et qui est ultra sexy stains bien sûr
mais n'hésite pas à affirmer que les
femmes doivent être en petite tenue pour
passer à la télé et elle est recrutée
sur ces critères en leur demandant de
montrer un petit peu leur forme en
casting voir plus de passer sous la
table
on aime bien ça donc c'est une histoire
vraie évidemment ça raconte l'une des
employées nicole kidman qui est
licenciée parce qu'elle devient trop
vieille pas assez cool pour la chaîne
passé dans la bulle temps et donc elle
décide cette fois de briser le silence
en entraînant d'autres filles derrière
elle par la suite et de dénoncer ce cas
est donc bon shell scandale c'est ça et
on voit aussi à travers ce film la
campagne de trump puisque ça se passe à
peu près la même période et donc la
fameuse fameuse race qu'il avait eue
envers une journaliste celle qui
interprétait par charlize theron ici qui
est de
qu'elle avait probablement ses règles
pendant l'interview c'est pour ça
qu'elle était un peu
voilà donc un film assez énervant quand
on est une femme
mais en même temps très bien traités
voilà le sujet est énervant mais le film
est très bien fait est important je
trouve et donc qui a permis au
licenciement de ce gars quoi qu'il n'est
plus à l'achat la tête de foxnews
maintenant et ça c'est plutôt
appréciable voilà donc je tiens bon film
ma série mais c'est bien foutu et bien
joué et surtout là c'est l'histoire qui
est importante qui mérite d'être connu
ensuite nous attaquons un film encore
une fois tiré d'un livre de personnes
aux esprits of david copperfield de
amendis iannucci avec dev patel peter
capaldi tilda swinton
hugh laurie ben whishaw bref un assez
gros casting et que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié donc encore une fois c'est une
adaptation dont je ne connaissais pas
l'histoire d'origine juste les grands
traits mais je n'avais jamais lu le
livre ni vu d'autres adaptations
ce que j'ai aimé dans cette version a
donc déjà j'ai découvert l'histoire qui
une très bonne histoire et elle est très
théâtral dans certains effets de mise en
scène par exemple déjà dans l'énergie le
rythme qui est donnée aussi donc dans
certains effets de mise en scène par
exemple quand on a des flashbacks
c'est pas juste une transition vers un
flashback parfois les personnages qui
sont en train d'avoir le flash backs
sont toujours à l'écran et le flashback
est projetée sur un mur par exemple
voilà c'est la seule chose dont je me
souviens la maintenant dans les effets
qui rappelait le théâtre mais j'ai
beaucoup aimé ça j'ai trouvé ça très
inventif
c'était très coloré aussi dans les
costumes dans la colorimétrie est encore
une chose qui me rappelait théâtre c'est
le choix du casting on n'a absolument
rien à de l'origine ethnique des
gens par exemple dev patel et joue david
copperfield donc c'est un acteur qui est
indien d'origine ses parents dans
l'histoire sont blancs jamais une et
relevé le fait qu'ils les indiens c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas l'importance
la couleur des gens dans ce film n'a
aucune importance
on a une actrice qui est noir dont le
père est asiatique
et voila quoi c et puis c'est juste un
personnage les gens sont des personnages
ne sont pas définies par leur couleur et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on trouve
beaucoup plus au théâtre qu'au cinéma où
on n'hésite pas au théâtre à apprendre
des acteurs de différentes origines ni
pour jouer différents personnages et au
cinéma ça fait souvent beaucoup plus
scandale par exemple quand on pense à
james bond
alors que là le parti pris c'est 200
et j'ai trouvé ça très
appréciable et donc au delà du fait que
le film m'a rappelé théâtre d'un coup
c'était cool bah c'était un très bon
film comme j'ai dit rythmé drôle très
bien joué forcément il ya plein de bons
acteurs dedans peter capaldi hugh laurie
je les adore et donc voilà je le
recommande c'est par un chef-d'oeuvre
il a ses petits défauts forcément
l'histoire ça reste du duo charles
dickens et donc c'est assez bon fond
tout est bien qui finit bien ça on s'en
doute mais c'est bien fait maintenant on
va parler de petit pays qui est un film
d'eric barbier avec jean paul rouve
djibril 22 puzzle et isabelle kavanaugh
encore une fois un livre tiré d'un roman
mais cette fois beaucoup plus récent
donc un roman de gaël faye mon petit
pays raconte l'histoire de gabrielle un
petit garçon qui grandit au burundi dans
les années 90 et dans les années 90 dans
cette région là le burundi le rwanda est
lieu le massacre des tutsis
je sais pas si vous connaissez sujet bon
je n'ai pas ici pour faire un cours
d'histoire même si ses propos la chaîne
habituellement mais en gros il y avait
des très grosses tensions entre les
hutus et les tutsis au rwanda
principalement est justement ce film m'a
permis de comprendre un peu mieux les
enjeux si j'aurais du mal à vous les
expliquer ici parce que vraiment c'est
pas ma spécialité de comprendre les
enjeux et de se rendre compte que bah
déjà ça ne concernait pas que le rwanda
que le burundi qui se trouve à côté
était concerné aussi puisqu'il y avait
pas également cette division là bas
c'est un film qui qui aborde ce génocide
sur fond de juste d'un enfant on suit
son parcours sa famille c'est un film
qui parle aussi de beaucoup d'autres
sujets et problèmes par exemple son père
et blanc son père c'est un on est plus
dans les colonies mais c'est un gars qui
est venu en afrique qui s'est marié avec
une femme noire et qui est un peu le
patron quoi là où ils se trouvent et ça
c'est aussi abordés dans le film par
exemple c'est un film dur évidemment on
est loin de david copperfield et de
court tout va bien la fin mais c'était
un film très bien fait très bas l'a
encore vu ce sujet qui est important
comme le cas de comme c'était le cas de
scandale par exemple et c'est pour ça
que le film est bon à voir je pense
parce qu'il est très réaliste il me
semble est aussi très bien joué
évidemment et voilà c'est l'histoire et
il faut voir cette histoire je pense
voilà bon on enchaîne sur deux gentlemen
qui est pas du tout dans la même
tonalité des dents dans le même style
voix de gentlemen c'est un film de guy
ritchie avec encore une fois un casting
assez important en amont matthew
mcconaughey charlie hunnam michel dault
kerry collins farrell hugh grant bref du
beau monde ne même pas citer tout le
monde bon l'entente u bon gros gag
richie en à un baron de la drogue qui
essayent de revendre sa petite
entreprise
on a des rebondissements des complots
des assassinats d enlèvement bref ça
part dans tous les sens c'est super
rythmé très bien jouer encore une fois
et que dire de plus
sega et richie évidemment on est loin de
la vie invisible de meetic et cauchemars
ou deux petits pays au niveau émotionnel
mais c'est pas ça qu'on recherche dans
ce film c'est un très bon divertissement
et je le recommande
et je termine avec deux paires fait
candidate de haifa al mansour avec mila
al zahrani je suis là je n'avais pas mis
dans mes films préférés mais il mérite
d'être mentionné je pense déjà parce que
je le savais pas quand j'ai vu le film
mais il est réalisé par la même personne
qui avait fait le biopic sur mary
shelley
il ya deux ans peut-être et j'avais
adoré ce biopic son ambiance son le
traitement de l'image tout était beau et
rennes pour ça du coup elle mérite
d'être à nouveau mentionné
c'est un film qui se passe en arabie
saoudite donc il traite d'une femme qui
est médecin déjà une femme médecin en
arabie saoudite on peut imaginer les
obstacles qu'elles rencontrent
et donc elle travaille dans une petite
clinique qui a très peu de moyens est le
seul moyen qu'elle trouve pour réussir à
débloquer des fonds à avoir des moyens
c'est de se porter candidate à la mairie
de la ville aux élections municipales
est donc une femme qui se portent
candidates aux élections municipales
évidemment ça pose pas de problème au
niveau de sa campagne au niveau de la
réception de du fait que ce soit une
femme rappelle qu'ont mené en arabie
saoudite où la situation n'est pas très
facile pour les femmes
donc ce que j'ai apprécié dans ce film
c'est justement de pouvoir découvrir un
sujet qu'on connaît on sait que les
femmes n'ont pas beaucoup de droit en
arabie saoudite
mais c'est bien de le voir en fait même
si c'est de la fiction je pense que
cette femme qui vit dans ce pays a placé
bon aperçu de ce qui s'y passe donc
j'aime quand les films me permettre de
découvrir des pays et des situations que
je connais peu et ça a été le cas de ce
film
après il est un peu mou par moments
voilà comme j'ai dit j'ai pas mis dans
mes films préférés mais je pense que
c'est quand même un film à voir pour
découvrir la situation qui on ne connaît
pas c'est une assez bonne porte d'entrée
hdmi
voilà et donc c'est tout pour cette
liste évidemment j'ai vu d'autres films
que j'ai pas aimé y en a que j'ai un peu
mmic pour moi méritait pas quand même
d'être mentionnée au final j'ai pas
beaucoup moins de films que les années
précédentes mais forcément j'en ai vu
beaucoup moins donc il ya d'autres films
que j'aurais voulu voir j'ai toujours
pas vu étaient 85 par exemple qui
apparemment était bien je peux vous
demanderont mal non plus qui vient de
sortir mais apparemment il est pas bien
donc c'est pas grave
et donc voilà pour conclure cette vidéo
j'espère que l'année 2000 21 nov
métras de voir un petit peu plus de
films mais surtout que le monde ira
mieux parce que c'est un reste c'est le
plus important quand même je pense que
alors vous verrez cette vidéo nous
serons déjà en 2021
puisque je tourne ceci un 31 décembre et
que même si je ne fais pas la fête ce
soir je vais quand même pas fut passé ma
soirée à faire du montage donc bonne
année à vous
en espérant qu'elle soit meilleure et on
se retrouve très vite pour de l'histoire
au jour de l'histoire dont j'ai un
j'arrive à plus à faire qu'une vidéo par
mois mais c'est parce que je prends
beaucoup de temps dans les recherches
bas et du coup pour une recherche
d'ailleurs l'objet de passer par des
articles que je trouve en ligne donc ça
va je trouve beaucoup de choses quand
même mais ça me prend un peu plus de
temps bizarrement que quand j'allais à
la bibliothèque etc ou de consulter des
livres
donc je pour ça on va rester sur ce
rythme d'une vidéo par mois il y aura
plein de bonnes choses pour l'année 2000
21 jeux déjà un planning à peu près
établi et voilà
et bien bonne année à tous et à bientôt
pour de l'histoire salut